and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb
tonight's review
Speed Racer
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life there's this
kid named Speed Racer someone actually
named the Speed Racer I can't believe
that but cruel parents and he likes to
go driving and dress up like a sperm
which is why they call him sperm racer
and he's in the classroom drawing Dutch
drawings come to life and suddenly he is
a racecar driver pretty pictures it was
kind of like being on drugs except I
wasn't on drugs I'm watching this movie
thinking I would be on drugs when I
looked and I wasn't i drugged it's like
drugs without drugs it's that good if
you're not high by the time you go into
this movie you definitely will be by the
time you leave and Wednesday from The
Addams Family is in it except she's not
a little girl anymore
he's got the the she's not a little girl
anymore
his brother is killed because a mountain
eats him and he's like I'm a big
mountain and I'm going to eat you and
sperm raisers like you're my brother
eats like nah man I'm the guy from lost
and everybody is dressed up like candy
it made me so hungry
I bought some M&Ms and I smoked it in
the bathroom and there's this bad guy
who I think is Al Gore after he ate Tim
Curry and he's like racing is fixed
sperm racers like no it isn't yes yes it
is so sperm man gets depressed but this
child and a monkey comes along all great
films have monkeys remember toss booth
that had a monkey in its way no there
was a submariner submarines are not
monkeys they are human beings so anyway
he's like I'm going to go back to racing
to beat the British bad guy because he's
British and therefore it's nabhi and me
except for the Munchie fight that guys
there they're cool the trailer house was
British I couldn't believe it I was
super treat but that doesn't matter
we get to the final race it's just like
a game of Mario Kart except Mario is a
sperm and everybody else's candy he
drives this will suspend and I think by
the end he has an orgasm I'm not sure
that could have been just me and
everybody's happy per racer he's happy
Wednesday's happy I was happy and they
play his famous song racer he's very
cool he's not food he made rides in
school and they would he swims in pools
his name rhymes with sue from
ghostbusters ok actually I didn't watch
most of it I was just so happy to be in
a warm warm building it's so cold
outside the popcorn off the floor was
very good I don't get to be indoors very
often I actually live in the box and
before that I lived in a cab and before
that I lived in the bag and before that
I lived in a pie it's not very easy to
live in a pie as Paulie sure he lived in
a pie right next to me so anyway if you
like being in warm warm building see
Speed Racer because they are mostly
shown in Warren Warren buildings this is
Chester a bum saying change you can't
change I come on help a guy out will you
come on change come on man I lived in a
pie